he has been rocking the beats since the
very beginning I'm talking about boom
boom pow it's when we first heard of
beats from will.i.am Black Eyed Peas
frontman is the founding shareholder of
Beats Electronics and last week Apple
abide by agreed to buy this business for
a whopping three billion dollars I had a
chance to sit down with will.i.am and
ask what this deal means to him
in 2004 Black Eyed Peas we launched
iTunes
hey mama was the song for the first
iTunes commercial and that took us
around the world and I saw the world
totally different because people
witnessed and experienced concerts
differently the simple fact that a
camera was on a phone people watch
concerts like this so what happened
after that tour was I came home and I
told Jimmy Jimmy we need to make
hardware we need to be in the hardware
industry our music is selling other
people's stuff we need to have hardware
so that when we go out there and put out
music its selling our stuff no more
selling other people's stuff so Jimmy
really took that to heart and and I've
been a part of beats since the beginning
then what do you get out of this now
beat sells to Apple what does this mean
for you it means that I can go out there
and do more wild and crazy stuff around
consumer electronics I could more
importantly the work that I do with my
community I could I could help out more
kids and you know my I am angel program
teaches kids science technology
engineering mathematics and now I don't
necessarily have to go out and just
raise money so I can I could tend to the
kids that I've already committed myself
to helping out and bring in tools to my
own is there a risk at all you are a
creator you went to Jimmy and said we
need to make our own hardware
now that hardware is essentially owned
by the man a bunch bigger man Apple so
is your creativity limited now that you
all don't own what you do I don't look
at Apple as demand I look at Apple as a
very awesome company that makes tools
that I create music on like I make my
music on Apple products
and you go around the world and people
that listen to music on Apple products
so Apple is not I don't know what the
man means right I don't that's yester
world right now we're in this a
collaborative state of culture where you
know big companies are going and
collaborating with the unlikely
candidate whether for marketing
consulting creative consultant stuff
like that right so the purchase of beats
is a sign to show you where things are
going and it's the hybrid of tech and
culture do we run the risk for artists
out there that these tech companies are
cannibalizing them streaming music does
it hurt the artists who used to create
his own music and sell it out of the
back of a car now that streaming service
is getting me my music I'm not buying it
from the artist now you just drove into
a very very complex web if you want to
talk about that I'm willing to give you
some information on just how how artists
are being screwed but more importantly
how an artist has showed you the way on
how to do it Dre artist showed you the
way of how to do it mean how artists
have showed you the way how to do it
jay-z I know there's other well there's
another there's other wait there's other
ways of making money than just selling
music now that beats has a home at Apple
do you see a new music label opening do
you see a new home for emerging artists
you've got a much bigger platform um I
don't I don't know the details on what
is going to come but I know how it's
going to spark a light I hope it sparks
a fire and other artists out there to
take an interest in consumer electronics
but more importantly I hope this puts a
spark in kids in inner cities so not
only are they trying to get out the
ghetto singing and playing sports but
now they could discipline themselves
around science and technology so they
too could bring a beats to culture